seeing all of that will require
sanitation and protocols that
will indeed be costly and we need to
supplement what our providers
are getting in terms of their support
and make sure that we are hitting
uh that issue uh head-on of course
data and we can talk for hours and hours
about large-scale procurement of i.t
in this state uh and we are turning the
page some of those
efforts we have a lot more to say that
topic in the next
month since the next year's budget issue
of i.t
and data management is critical and i'll
just end on this
pass it over to dr galley because i
think it's important because it's always
been stubborn
point concern as it relates to anything
we do at scale
and our ability for existing systems to
manage at the scale of a pandemic
i'll remind you that there are two
it strategies you have the interface
with the public which is our current
california
immunization registry it's an existing
platform called the care system that's
already
in place it's a relatively relatively
good
system but it's not good enough we
believe to address
all of the needs in the state and that's
why we have been going through an
advanced procurement process
we're looking as early as the next 10
days to get the finalists
signed off to do an end-to-end i.t
strategy that's why you see
in this slide two phases of i.t
development
both december as early as december 1st
and january but also
it's critical that we lock in with
our providers and that's the clinics and
the hospitals et cetera
the distribution that eventually will be
out into
many of the pharmacies in the state that
we have provider registration reporting
tracking
ordering all of that needs to feed into
our state system
not just that direct interface with
users uh
through the care system so all of that
we've been working on
all of that is nearing critical decision
making
um in the next few weeks and in
the next few months so that's a an
update
on where we are on vaccinations uh we
are making
real progress i'm very proud of the
teams that we have pre-assembled
we're not reacting to this moment we've
leaned into it
we've been proactive in closing before i
turn over dr galley
we also are blessed to be supported by
the new uh
covet advisory committee that vice
president uh elect now president rather
elect joe biden has organized that
included includes by the way one of our
scientific safety review committee
members
that the president-elect took to be part
of the national advisory committee this
in addition to those other californians
that are also on that national advisory
committee
so we're very blessed to have strong
relationships
uh with the current uh administration
vis-a-vis this vaccination strategy
and even stronger still with the
incoming
administration but with that i want to
now turn it over to dr galley
and talk about incoming and that is the
number of inquiries that he has received
around gatherings for thanksgiving
uh and uh the likelihood that
we will see an increase in spread of
transmissions
as we see more and more mixing and what
we are doing to prepare for that
some of the messaging that we predates
today on the travel advisories and some
of the
issues related to that 10 uh to 5 a.m
non-essential uh activities that will
lead into
being more safe and working our way
through this holiday season with that
dr galley rade
thank you governor and uh thank you all
all for tuning in governor you
as always did a tremendous job
explaining where we are on what is a
really hopeful topic which is
vaccinations uh
california is preparing has been
preparing
and is ready uh to work with our local
partners our federal partners to make
sure
that vaccines which are really weeks
away for some populations
uh are are ready and that we use it as
the important tool that they are
but now uh more than ever with that
hopeful news it's important that we keep
our guard up and we keep
doing the things that we've been talking
about over the last many months
it's not that there's uh uh
a promise that everyone will get the
vaccine in the first few months of the
year but some of our most vulnerable
individuals those who are working on the
front lines of our hospitals that are
exposed
almost every day to covet 19 will be
protected that's great news for our
communities
and it tells me and tells us that the
dependence on
continuing to keep our guard up
like we can make it we can do this as a
state and we've done it before and we
need to continue doing that and
with this thanksgiving holiday coming up
it's an important week to emphasize
all of those protective factors and the
governor mentioned on an earlier slide
that
just 60 of our cases
are or a full 60 of our cases
are among those 19 to 49 years old
so a vast majority of the cases
uh or those who we test who are infected
are in that age category yet they make
up
only seven percent of those who
have the worst outcome in death in this
state
so let me say that again 60 of cases yet
only 70
of our deaths the real story in that is
where are all the deaths happening and
that is
because although it's only 10 of our
cases
for those over the age of 65 full 75
of california's deaths have been in that
older
age group so what does it mean for our
traditional thanksgiving
celebrations or celebrations in the many
weeks to come when we bring together
many generations for traditions and
celebration and a great time together
that those younger individuals who
many are not sick or not very sick
not sick at all they're the asymptomatic
or pre-symptomatic individuals
folks who will never need to go into an
urgent care center an emergency room or
be admitted
that they are exactly the individuals we
are the individuals who can spread
covet 19 to our older family members our
older
friends our own older loved ones and
in that risk we need to just be very
careful
we know that our hospitals already are
seeing levels of surge that they've
never seen before
even at the height of our june and july
peak of cases we now have hospitals
across the state that are telling us
that their census the number of people
with coven 19 in their hospitals
is higher than it's ever been and we
know that cases are still
rising and the overall average number of
cases over a seven day period
is a lot higher than what it used to be
so what that means is we need to do
our part we need to help stop the spread
and recognize that the days to come
are really important what our decisions
are i've had countless conversations
with
friends and family but a lot of
californians who've reached out and said
you know we've decided to change what
our thanksgiving meal looks like instead
of doing it
later in the day we're going to move it
up we're going to try to move it outside
to catch a little bit of the warmer
weather thankfully
it looks like we'll have some sun on
that day that there are some options
even at this day
just a few days ahead to change that
plan and maybe do something slightly
differently
so we know that this is all part of
stopping the spread
doing our part and hopefully helping get
california through the next many weeks
as we anticipate uh parts of our
communities getting the vaccine
next slide so the clearest guidance is
celebrate with your own household
uh there's lots of ways to connect with
those that you love i know that
we're going to be zooming with loved
ones my mom in particular
a lot of the day on thursday uh uh
traditionally she'd come and visit us
and be with our family but we're going
to keep it safe
and zoom and interact with her that way
um
of course we know that uh some people
are not able to prepare a meal and maybe
that's the urge to gather with them
but there's other ways to support those
individuals to
make that connection dropping off a meal
and then sharing it
when you zoom together these are all
options that give us
opportunities to lower our risk lower
the risk of others
but hopefully still have that important
connection that we all look forward to
during these uh upcoming holidays
so as we end every time and before i
take it back over to the governor and
open it up for questions just remind you
of these four basic things and
you know even as i put it up i i uh
you know really want to push forward
this idea that yeah you've heard wear
the mask
and many of you are tired of wearing it
but we ask you as much as you can to
keep it on
we put out the guidance we let you know
how and where to use your mask
but it's really a choice that each of us
has to make
and not just make in the morning and uh
you know but something we have to make
throughout the day
physically distance that's a important
thing hard to do
when we're keeping our distance from
loved ones but
all the more important now washing our
hands
and minimizing the mixing and this
really comes back to
in the days to come keeping it with our
households
and um uh reaching out to loved ones in
a different way
than we normally do so with that uh look
forward to
uh the questions and governor back to
you great thank
you thank you of course now we're happy
to take any questions
difficulties and so before figuring that
out
dr galley just because the awkward
silence maybe i'll just ask you as we
figure out
uh the calls question about the issue of
travel advisory what that means
vis-a-vis thanksgiving obviously so much
the national attention has been focused
on
airports and people uh traveling
out all across this country coming back
into the state of california after
traveling in other parts of the country
perhaps you can give us a sense of what
your what your
reason we put out that advisory and your
concerns in that space
yeah thanks governor and and like many
other parts of the nation
we're concerned about people traveling
during the holiday season
that they go and they're in an
environment maybe where
transmission rates are much much higher
much of the country's experiencing
higher
rates of transmission than california
and visiting even
just a few friends keeping it short and
coming back
just those travels expose you to a level
of
covid19 that as you come back into the
state we're really
uh encouraging you to do do what you're
doing governor which is quarantine
make sure that you weren't infected that
you don't end up inadvertently passing
it on to other
uh members of your community and we can
keep the spread low so
we know that even across the state we're
asking you to keep
as local as you can don't travel um
beyond just a couple few hours
from your home so that you can also keep
keep the spread down in our state and
that isn't an unusual thing a lot of
states
have pushed travel advisories travel
restrictions and we're among
those and have done it with our partners
around the west coast
to make sure that we all keep ourselves
protected
keep transmission as low as possible and
it makes a key difference that 14 days
that people
come in a lot of folks are looking at
that closely making sure that it's the
right amount of time
and for now that's what we understand to
be the
incubation period the time by which
somebody
might be exposed and by the time they're
no longer infectious and
so that's why we have that 14-day number
as well governor
doctor last week in sort of anticipating
a question as we figure this out
uh you you announced on friday this
non-essential
recommendation people past 10 p.m to 5
a.m
for non-essential activities and on
monday
uh basically implied that we were not
only looking at it but that we were
looking at the studies the efficacy of
of of these efforts around the world i
think
referred to three specific studies last
monday that we had reviewed that you had
provided
your team and reviewed et cetera the
work that was done in virginia relating
to
alcohol consumption massachusetts other
parts of the country that have
limited versions including many cities
not just states maybe you can
give folks that may not have tuned in
friday an overview of what the thinking
was in terms of that
recommendation and why you think it's
important at this stage
sure i think i mean two very important
ones one is
uh really we we want to continue to
communicate and provide
uh provide information to all of
californians that
where we are right now is different than
where we were before we're in a
point of surge that we have to take out
all of the tools in our toolbox
uh and and apply them here and it is in
part
a symbol and a message to all of our uh
public that what we're facing every
little bit matters
and i was asked you know why is it the
ten to five that's special
uh one reporter said can the can covet
tell time and i said
you know handily no of course uh there's
there's no reason why between 10 and 5
a.m
uh doing the exact same things done at
10
in the morning that provide will behave
any differently but what we do know and
what you alluded to
is that oftentimes during that time
period
uh non-essential gatherings
non-essential
coming together really does happen
without
the best protective tools people take
off their mask they come a little closer
than they should
they uh uh you know celebrate and
and do certain things that allow
transmission to go
pretty quickly i say that covet goes
from 0 to 60
in no time and that happens when all
those protective factors are down
so you know this is a tool for us across
california in our purple counties that
are facing the worst
of our surge to be additive with all the
other tools that we have
and we hope and we're looking closely at
our data
to see if that begins to turn the tide
on these
impressive case numbers and hopefully in
time to keep our hospitals
in good shape so we can continue to
provide care to those who need it and
who are sick
and and before we we open up the
questions and it looks like we
finally figured that out i just want to
just
ask you one additional question in
anticipation question
it's been brought up a number of times
and we made the point last week that we
were putting this emergency break on as
it relates to our tiered status
rather than waiting until traditional
tuesday announcement
your tuesday at noon announcement on new
tears we moved on monday
we made the point that we will in real
time continue and assess
if we were going to move tears uh
in based upon the epidemiology based
upon the spread
on friday there was a review you made
the determination
that we were not moving forward uh just
preview a little bit
uh tomorrow you will be making
announcements updating based upon the
data getting this weekend
maybe you can just preview a little bit
about what you expect to be saying
tomorrow
yeah so uh thanks governor yes uh just
to reiterate we did as you promised
looked at the data at the end of last
week and ran it like
we do every week and indeed no
additional counties made
tear movement so we didn't and we agreed
that if a county needed to move we would
move them quickly
so that we could begin to stem the tide
on the surge in those areas
tomorrow we anticipate that there will
be some tier movement
handful of counties likely moving to a
more restrictive tier
and maybe even a county or two uh that
that are showing that they are getting
containment on the virus
and potentially meeting that one week
mark
to move forward so again a mixed picture
across california
we are always looking at the data trying
to be as current as we can
and we report it as such and we treat
counties as such
you have said that california shouldn't
be
uh treated in the aggregate that we have
regions we have counties we have
differences between
the northern and the southern parts of
our state the inland and the coastal
and indeed that's what we see with all
of these numbers so tomorrow we will
have an update on our tier status
and uh more specifics uh tomorrow at
noon
excellent with that we uh happy now
answer any questions
does he have a log sacramento b
hi doctor can you hear me perfectly
great i'm gonna go ahead and ask the
question that my colleague adam beam of
the ap
tried to ask um we could hear him on the
line but it sounds like you couldn't
um he wanted to know if you have uh
lost credibility after photos have
circulated
of you at the birthday party earlier
this month
you weren't wearing a mask in those
photos and yet you were talking very
closely with other people
um can you speak to that and tell us
what precautions you were taking at that
party suddenly taken precautions but it
was not clear that that was happening
from those photos
yeah no i made a mistake i apologized we
had dinner
uh four o'clock dinner in an orange
tiered
county we're not telling people they
can't eat
uh but indeed i made a mistake being
with few
extra people beyond uh the guidelines
that i've been promoting which is
outside the households that was a
mistake
um and i let my guard down and i
apologize for it
and uh and we're moving to correct that
in terms of
uh working hard working harder every
single day
never made that mistake before i haven't
made it since and i won't make it again
period full stop
emily hogan cal matters
hey governor um as you know uh the state
controller betty he
has been saying for months the secretary
of state's office
doesn't have budgetary authority to pay
for a 35 billion dollar contract
awarded to sdd ickerbocker um do you
think the controller should approve
payment of the contract and do you think
it was appropriate
the secretary of state to award such a
big contract to a firm
involved in joe biden's presidential
campaign i'll leave
i'll leave the controllers perfectly
situated
first of all deep admiration for our
controller
uh and her character her competency
and her judgment the controller is
reviewing that
she will make an independent assessment
uh and i look forward to that review
and to her counsel i will happily answer
that question after i have the benefit
of her review and independent analysis
alex michaelson fox 11.
thank you governor first off nice
bookcase
secondly i'm wondering um how does this
experience for you of quarantining at
home
maybe change the way you think about
this experience that so many
californians have gone through
and a follow-up to the question about
the curfew which i appreciate you asking
dr
galley a few moments ago um but i talked
uh on friday with dr burks at the white
house about
the science behind curfew she said she
didn't want to second guess your
decision but pointed to like
miami where they get a curfew and they
found that it didn't really work because
it drove a lot of people to
go to house parties which ended up
spreading the virus more
and i'm wondering if you can expand upon
the science of
the curfew decision and that concern
that it might
lead to other worst behavior well and
and i i really appreciate that question
i'll ask
dr gali uh answer that more specificity
but you may recall last monday i implied
uh my own hesitancy as relates to
being open to argument interested in
evidence based upon the studies that
have been conducted and we have
the benefit of three studies and and
some show some very positive
behavioral changes others a little more
inclusive so i'm very
aware uh of of that in the context of
this
ongoing debate uh but we based upon
not only the analysis and review of
those studies but based upon
our engagement with our colleagues
across this country health officers
across the country other governors uh
and their review
uh based upon all of that we made the
assessment uh that we wanted to give
this a go dr gallagher
could talk more specifically about his
independent analysis
and not just the analysis that was
conducted in those three studies
that we were referring to yeah uh thank
you for the question and
and i'll tell you one of the things that
we did i believe differently
than some other uh states with a curfew
and remember we called ours a limited
stay at home
because part of the uh entire approach
and concept was
not just to ask business sectors
to stop operating between those times of
10
and 5 a.m but also that household
gathering
shouldn't occur so you know the guidance
isn't just
a let's not do it in the businesses in
the restaurants and the bars and the
other
areas or even outside in the open and
although really difficult to enforce or
regulate
the signal and the message is and don't
take these same activities indoors
because that's exactly where uh
spread could occur so it was meant to
complement
the other effects of curfews from other
areas
and enhance it with an additional
restriction
for the time limited period of uh
about four weeks 30 days in the purple
counties
so it's really that sort of one two
punch to try to reduce
transmission across our state and so
that's i mean the bottom line is
none of us are ideological about this in
the spirit of your question
uh we are opened argument interested in
evidence we've
committed to a four-week process based
upon
significant increase in uh and
transmission rates
uh we believe in a more targeted and
effective strategy than just going back
uh to a full lockdown in the state of
california based
upon where we are today and so that was
the determination
we're leaning into that and we will be
very cognizant
of its uh its cause and effect
and we are very very open about it not
stubborn
about that analysis and review that said
let me answer the first part of your
question
um clearly anyone that's prone to
uh be with their kids isolated or
quarantined
for many many days um it is a very
challenging and trying time and it's
certainly
uh something that is now been brought
home
quite literally in terms of my own
experience just over the course the last
couple days
that said i have deep empathy and
respect for people
they don't have the supports of people
that are in my position that don't have
the resources of people in my position
and those that are struggling you can't
even imagine
uh being a day away from work or a day
or two away
from loved ones that need to be in their
care
at the same time we are encouraging them
to isolate
and quarantine that's why we have put
out many many different supports
over the course of many many months
either through executive order and
or the leadership that demonstrably was
exampled
by the legislature this year that they
provided in terms of providing
economic stipends providing additional
supports and protections
illegal and otherwise and why it's
absolutely essential
that as we move forward not just as a
state but as a nation
that the federal government wake up and
recognize this moment we can simply
no longer wait for a new stimulus days
are becoming weeks
weeks becoming months we are at
peril uh at the end of this calendar
year
uh putting people's lives quite
literally at risk
of the economy much much more harm and
families
uh in much in positions of being much
more vulnerable so all of that
is brought uh in clear uh unambiguous
focus
as it relates to one's personal
experience uh but also recognizing the
experience that millions of americans
have hundreds of thousands that are
struggling in even more dire and
difficult circumstances
john myers l.a times thank you governor
can you hear me clearly before i begin
yes i can hear me yes
okay thank you very much i just wanted
to check because we don't have the
ability to do follow-up questions in
this
i wanted to know because the beginning
of your presentation
was muted we could not hear it if you
talked about what's going on with your
family can you talk about that and
here's what i'd like to have you focus
on if you could
you could tell us what your family knew
and when they knew it uh
give us a little bit more information
about when do you do of information
about the chp officer who tested
positive
are there additional officers in that
team who tested positive
um and and then also trying to
understand
the universe that your family operates
in you mentioned that other families are
not
as fortunate but we understand kind of a
sense of for lack of a better term the
pot
that your family lives in do you have
other support people house cleaners or
child care assistants that help with
your children
and are you considering sending the
children back to school when they're
done or does this give you second
thought if
one of your children was exposed by a
classmate you know the school made that
decision independently
uh and they have paused so that was
determined by
the school itself as it relates to uh my
three children that were exposed
um it was a chp officer and they were
exposed
a four-year-old was exposed first so
forgive me i don't have
the ability to acquire when he knew and
how he knew it because of his age
all of them below the age of 11 years
old but when we discovered or rather we
were told of the positive
case and the fact that the chp officer
was in close contact
with those three kids we immediately
went through the process of protocols
and reviews that are well established by
the state
and also went to greater lengths to get
more specificity about
local guidelines as well to make sure uh
that we were abiding by those as well we
chose to wait based upon
the the review or rather
based upon the recommendation of a local
health officer
in my case folks that work on our team
they were
required that well they were courage
rather not required that
we wait uh 48 hours to be tested because
they didn't want a false sense of of
negative tests to come in and so we
tested officially yesterday
after we discovered this on friday so
friday
uh waited until sunday to be tested test
results came back
late on sunday came back negative uh and
we officially started the quarantine
clock
uh on sunday well it was informal
through the weekend
as it relates to the house um i'm
blessed because
uh we have many rooms i'm able to do
this without kids jumping on top of me
i'm
in an office i can assure you first time
i've ever had
an office i used a smaller room in an
office was used for many other things in
the past that's
a blessing and i recognize that many
people don't even have the ability to do
what i'm doing
uh right here um and so that's number
one
uh number two no one else is in the
household uh we have
someone that has been with us um
that comes from overseas she's been
living with us for many many months
she's part of
the pod that's it she was tested tested
negative
as well
jeremy white politico thank you so much
for taking my question um i would like
to first quickly follow up on john's
question
and get any more detail on when your
children
came into contact with the infected
officer was driving them somewhere et
and i hate to be the reporters of the
two questions but um
it's been a couple weeks now since a
judge issued an injunction telling you
to
uh no longer alter state law
with executive orders i hope you can
tell us about what that injunction is of
hell
might mean for your ability to deal with
the pandemic through executive action
yeah we are appealing that decision and
uh will be adjudicated by
the appellate court more confident in
our legal standing and legal position
it's foundational
in terms of governing a state in a time
of crisis
uh it's a profoundly important decision
that will ultimately be made
uh through the deliberative process and
independent adjudication
uh by the california court uh of appeals
or at least the appellate level and
based upon their jurisdiction that said
this relates to uh the impact yes the
officer was in close contact
uh with three of our kids not one of our
kids three of our kids
uh and based upon the fact that they
were in close contact and they tested
positive and we learned that
uh we went through a series of protocols
that i just laid out
and gave to john and those protocols
led to tests all family members uh
including my youngest four-year-old
which was an episode itself
um just trying to encourage
four-year-olds to sit
uh and get tested with nasal swab
and fortunately all uh all of us in the
household
uh currently in this household uh all
tested negative we will do subsequent
tests
uh and we will abide by not just state
guidelines but uh
the county guidelines as well and that
quarantine process began
on this weekend and will continue for 14
days
final question ashley zavala next our
media group
hi governor i did want to ask a couple
simple questions about your quarantine
one
how are you feeling and two have you
been tested today i know your
communications office said that you
could test it every day
and i just wanted to see if that came
back negative yeah i know
well i've been tested a lot last few
weeks on multiple occasions the last few
weeks i
feel perfectly healthy i tested negative
yesterday and
i have no expectation that i'll test
any differently in subsequent days as we
apply
uh by these quarantine protocols and so
we'll let you know as we
get these subsequent tests the extent
you're interested uh but
uh currently uh those last well
we've never had a positive test i've
been tested many
many times i was stubborn you may recall
in the beginning of this pandemic
i did not get tested for many many
months i made it clear as to why i made
that determination
because so many others were not afforded
that privilege i wasn't going to extend
it uh and
now now with the availability of much
more testing
uh more would spread testing and the
fact you may recall that i
visited prisons i felt it incumbent upon
uh
me at that point to begin the testing
protocols and we've had fairly
consistent tests
not just the pcr tests those are ones uh
that are
the tests we make public but also these
anagen tests which i've taken on many
occasions
as well i don't have as much confidence
can we in those results why
we always have the backup pcr tests with
our foundational
pcr tests the ones the entire family
took
uh yesterday and pcr tests was what took
the previous week
as well in multiple previous occasions
so we'll continue to
do all of that and and more will
continue also to keep you
and others informed on where what we're
doing and
where we're going uh i want to
acknowledge those that may
have inquired about where we are on
senate choice picks that that
termination has yet not yet been made
but progress
has been made in terms of getting closer
to that determination there's no
uh timeline that we have advanced or
considered
uh obviously we'll need to get it done
uh before
uh vice president elect kamala harris is
sworn in as the next vice president
united states
but that process continues uh we
continue to work
very very hard on the budget uh those of
you that may have had a question in the
queue about the budget
uh i am very aware and we've been
working overtime including
um over the course of this last week in
particular
to work to get this budget done which
has to be at least to the printers in
the middle
of december cognizant and mindful of the
myriad of needs throughout the state of
california but none
more important than public health and
economic recovery
the needs of our small businessmen and
women all up and down
the state of california i said that last
week and i'd be remiss of not repeating
that
today and you'll hear me repeat that
over and over and over again
i am deeply mindful with 41 counties in
these purple restrictive tiers
the impact that's had on small
businesses in particular
and all of the uncertainty around a new
ppp
uh distinguished from ppe as relates to
small business supports
which must be a top priority of a new
cares act a new stimulus
in this country we're going to do what
we can to
do more for our small businesses in this
state that is a top
priority with the budget team will be a
top priority i know with the california
legislature based upon
the conversations we've had and i'm
grateful that they recognize that
imperative
as well so public health public safety
continue
to monitor these counties and the
transmission rates in real time
we will maintain our engagement
and not only with you on a consistent
basis but
tomorrow just furtherance of that dr
gallery
will be updating on the tiered status
and we will
likely be making additional announcement
additional announcements
uh through the week uh and into next
week
uh this virus does not take holidays off
quite the contrary take care everybody
thank you for tuning in uh at least
to this rather unusual uh but
increasingly
familiar setting uh here at home
take care finished rounds in the medical
intensive care unit
and we are now seeing about 30 to 40
percent of our patients
with uh active coveted disease and
respiratory failure
many of them on mechanical ventilators
and some of them on ecmo
to sustain life i really don't want to
see you
in that situation we've had two
generations of patients
in our icu a mother and a daughter both
die
as a result of covid i think it's really
time to take this seriously
and reduce the spread of this disease
you